hey everyone John Roker here at the
Facebook LA Studios with the cast and
creator showrunner writer of this
incredible new show sorry for your loss
that's on Facebook watch I consumed 13
episodes of this show in one Sunday I
cried a lot so I'm excited to talk to
this cast and definitely the kid Stein
Keller about this show we have Elizabeth
Olsen Kelly Marie Tran Joe van a Depot
and Mamadou Watchi
yes and I want to ask you guys cuz this
deals with so many strong issues we have
the possibility of suicide interracial
relationships moving on from sudden loss
in your life and you all really dive
into this with rarely any moments of
levity through the show because it can
be like that life sometimes especially
in a process like this how do you all
unwind on the set after a scene or after
especially brutally emotional scene like
that like it happens in the show I hope
we made you laugh a couple times - yes
especially Kelly yeah but is there
anything like Janet McTeer is known for
a lot of like strong dramatic roles do
you all ever put whoopee cushions on her
chair are you serious I wouldn't do that
oh my god I think she would get a crack
she would love that might be right
I think she would enjoy that greatly
we're not a bunch of pranksters really
but we like each other
yeah yeah cuz you all have you're all on
cross paths I mean you're all across
sides sometimes when you're crossing
paths and I always find that interesting
to explore okay this was brought about
from a moment in college right is that
right oh no I was older but certainly a
moment yeah it was on Rd a weird year
were a few people in my life and died
and then um so it already felt like the
vultures were circling a little bit and
then
was a yeah a night that very much
resembled the flashback sequence in the
first episode and I've seen someone
where you know likes for the no a night
can't find her husband looks everywhere
um
and yeah it just that night I had this
thought on loop in my head that if my
husband died my life would be over but
my life could not be over because I was
still alive so what was I gonna do how
do you live a life that's over and found
him it was okay I mean I wasn't okay
like right I think everything from the
outside looks like it worked out but I I
felt changed by that night I think when
you go nose-to-nose with your worst
nightmare it's hard to come back the
same yeah and I that entire it was also
I just got married we just we live in
that summer so um it was that fall I
just kept wrestling with it I'm with
that nightmare and uh and this character
emerged and the more I thought about her
and the people in her life the less it
became me and my life and the more it
became holy them and then to to meet
Lizzie three years ago now he was more
maybe almost four years ago and sit down
with you and to know within five seconds
you were supposed to be this human to
meet Mamadou and giovanna and kelly
auditions and and know that they were
supposed to be these people
it felt you know like it's like when you
got a jigsaw puzzle you got three
missing pieces and it's you can see it
it's so close but then you just lock
those pieces and that's that's what it
was to to meet these amazing humans all
of a sudden the show was a show yeah and
it's such an incredibly diverse show as
well which I found to be so great for
for me to enjoy and see this process is
that I lost my father in 2008 to cancer
and watching your process as this
character there is so much I had
forgotten that I went through myself and
that's what's so fantastic about
watching a character the anger the
frustration the using it as a guilt card
at times when it's convenient because
you can't process what's happening how
much of this like excited you as an
actress
to enter and how much of it may be
changed you from the experience
afterwards well when I loved about kits
the first time reading kits pilot was I
had been playing characters that are
aside from me or I'd been playing parts
that were in different roles that I
learn more about and I was like ah she
sounds like me like I I can come across
a lot lately at times which isn't that
great for my Type A personality
but what I what I loved about it was how
specific it was to the experience of
grief I haven't personally lost anyone
that important to me I've lost important
people to me but not like a parent or a
spouse and so I mean there's vision but
other than that which by the way like
intersected with this show in a really
funny way it was really reading Joan
Didion's your magical thinking because
the way she writes about grief is so
specific and getting the hot like being
the person trying to hold on to the
memory and that's why memory became such
an important part of our show and like
not wanting to lose those memories and
keep the most specific and dirty and
real and honest as possible instead of
turning into this like blurry romantic
fantasy of this person being perfect
like you don't want that you want the
real thing and so that became a big part
of our show and it did change me because
I have cousins who have lost parents my
my uncle and I really didn't know at
Thanksgiving five years later if you
bring it up again
right and what I learned from doing this
show is people loved talking about the
people they loved even if they're gone
and so that was the thing I really took
away after the first season I was like
wow people like it shouldn't be that
awkward thing at dinner it's like no
one's gonna show you the obvious thing
like so-and-so died
and like or should I bring it up or
should I not or it's me so awkward if I
bring it up and I think people really do
want to talk about the people they love
and those kinds of conversations I feel
like if you have more of them people
will would understand the process a bit
more such an isolating experience you
destroy the stigma of it be by showing
the reality of it right I think that's
what the show does really really well it
does not pull punches on the
authenticity of the experience another
one jewels are Kelly what you go through
with jewels also the addiction dealing
with the guilt that's being thrown at
you from other people people being
afraid you're gonna relapse all the time
this is such a how much responsibility
did you feel to create a real
interpretation of someone who's coming
off an addiction in trying to go on with
her life like how much research did you
do for Jewel's a lot of yeah I felt a
lot of responsibility and I think the
thing that really sort of tied me to
jewels in a way was I have friends who
were addicts and I I do think that
everyone is sort of an addict in a way
like we all have our addictions but what
was really important to me about this
character is I didn't want her to feel
as if she's like here's me always
talking about my addiction I'm always so
you know what I mean a I wanted her to
feel like she was a person walking
around the world who had this experience
but was trying not to be defined by it
and the only reason why she was is
because the people in her world
continued to define her that way and I
think that's really real to life a lot
of the times when we're trying to be new
people or trying to mean these things a
lot of the times the things that hold us
back are the people that love us the
most not consciously but because they
can't see past the things that you've
done so yeah it was really big for me I
read all the I read the book yeah it was
it was a whole delving into and it
continues to be this season is different
things but we have that moment in the
first season where you're like I need to
get away from this family I need to find
my own voice and even they resist you
doing that because they need you to fit
in this particular box so that they can
function in their world but you've
become the character that I watched them
like I'm cheering for you the most as I
watch these episodes because all of a
sudden in the first season it becomes
about you
story we were following Leafs alone all
of a sudden becomes about your story and
this is a nice interesting turn at the
show does that I really think speaks
highly of it right yeah there is um you
know we are very aware that we have ten
episodes a half-hour each and so we're
playing musical chairs a little bit and
and trying to make sure that every
character an actor really gets their
moment gets their due but we have a
limited real estate so we um and I
really that really in season two we do
see the musical chairs of it all the
spotlights here then it's here then it's
here
but ultimately I'm really proud of the
of the quilt that all those patchworks
create yeah and and another two pieces
of those quilts is your relationship
that you have Jovan and Mama did the
relationship you have together as
brothers this is not an easy
relationship and I remember him remember
interviewing the the directors for the
last black man in San Francisco and one
of the things he talked about was that
we're finally starting to see more
layered representations of black men in
shows how you know we deal with
interracial relationships in the show we
deal with your relation relation with
your mom and the abuse of the dad like
how much of that echoed in your own
lives or how much of that have you
experienced with other people to bring
to these roles as well on the show like
the complex dynamic of that when it
comes to like siblings and things like
that outside of my family I mean even I
guess if I'm looking a little bit me and
my brother have had that in the past and
we get along great now but it's uh it's
definitely something that I was able to
pull from as far as like most of the
confrontation between mm-hmm it's mine I
think I just I thought we just kind of
built on like a was that the dance of
when you met there were the ears fell on
the sword for someone else I was trying
to just but like you know we just you
know
honestly built off the rapport any have
and use the script as a guide yeah it's
not a standard thing do you like their
exploring more like okay you're a you're
a comic nerd and there's there's a big
parameter
what's yeah and that's that I'm saying
there's been a bigger push to recognize
that they're the comics aren't just for
the white audiences the black audiences
Latino audiences Asian audiences it's
there did you like that aspect of the
character oh yeah it's something that I
always kind of look look for I mean
vulnerability in black men has a bomb
screen has been underrepresented like
throughout like the wall growing up and
like with them I say often like had I
graduated 10 years ago I don't know if
I'd have the same career um which is
nuts
right um but I'm you know sign of times
that things are changing hopefully you
continue to change in a positive way and
yeah this show is one of those one of
those shows that I really yeah push up
for it I got I know I got a wrap up but
I giovanna gosh yeah danny is becoming
someone that I am now fascinated by as
he starts to now as you were saying kid
earlier now the musical chair seems to
be on him cuz in the second in the first
season we got a lot of we got a lot of
Danny but we wanted more of Daniel Ike
what's his process and how we're seeing
this the that you know what you're going
into the surfing stuff all of that
moving out I go experiencing all this
kind of stuff like what is what what
excites you about Danny in the second
season I think it's just the opportunity
to show another perspective on getting
through grief and trying to get through
just life obstacles in general like you
were saying Danny gets a chance to try
all these different things and he really
is trying to just feel what feels good
to him and he's trying to chase that
feeling like in whatever way he can so
it was really cool to just get involved
in different things throughout the
season and continue to build upon the
relationships of the rest of my cast
mates yeah really cool I'm only three
episodes into the second season so I'm
looking forward to see more I was told
that three more episodes are waiting for
me so I can't wasn't a first season as
well four five and six with a big and
that's the last thing I want to say to
you all is I really appreciate the way
you confront the possibility of mental
health and suicide here because you
don't really a hundred percent settle
the issue
at least at this point that that's
happened and it's more about the fact
that he's gone and it's less about the
fact that what happened and that's
another way to destroy the stigma as you
were taught as we were talking about
earlier destroying the stigma of that
it's a disease
this killed I didn't make a chair she
didn't make a choice this and that I
think that's a powerful message for the
show yeah I was I had heard in the wake
of on someone I knew that a diet was
resolved suicide n/a was it was um yeah
it was something their child said that
really just still is a knife and my gut
and you never forgot it and it really
felt and that's what you do was as a
writer as you just you know these these
things happen to you in life and there's
like nice and your and your gut and you
sometimes if you're fortunate you have a
story and a platform an opportunity and
you can kind of like remove that mic and
stick it in the story or you keep in
your back pocket and then you just place
it in the story gently that's maybe a
less violent no I think it's no it was I
felt that I'm nurse season finale last
year that that was the right moment to
have that conversation so I'm glad it
resonated with you that means a lot
absolutely it's fantastic and one less
thing is I'm with Collider I have to ask
you Elizabeth what is the most what is
the thing you're most excited to show
people in one division may I ask Wanda
well thanks everybody for watching with
the past and the Creator I'm sorry for
you loss please for the love of God
watch this show it's one of the best
things I've ever watched and one of the
most authentic slices of real life and
our world now and the issues were
confronting as human beings so watch
this thing we'll talk to you soon